okay hero someone must warn Jessica
Hayes the Indiana woman who participated
in a rare Catholic wedding ceremony
where she married Jesus not to expect
too much from the honey I don't know
what you said or the delusion that Jesus
would even want to marry you or all
those wasted hours striking a seductive
pose on the bed waiting for him to come
out of the bathroom knurl now that idaho
has had to replace their highways mile
420 markers
with ones that read mile four 19.9
because potheads predictably kept
stealing the sign say 420 they have to
turn it into a math problem if a carload
of stoners starts out traveling at 19
miles an hour in the fast lane and stops
to giggle at the mile 69 how long before
they realize they're headed in the wrong
direction
you're already pandas have to admit that
they're actually plush toys nothing
could possibly be this cute somewhere
there are a couple of baby seals
thinking well we had a pretty good run
didn't we
nero hillary clinton has to stop always
looking like she's doing stand-up
hey what's the deal with Benghazi why do
they always call about terrorist attacks
right when you get in the shower
although Jerry Seinfeld would be jealous
of the email scandal it really is a show
about nothing neural somebody needs to
tell Hardee's and Carl's jr. that
they're not fooling anybody come on guys
it's 2015 and you guys have been
together for 20 years now if we can
handle the truth so let's stop
pretending that you have two different
places come out in the daylight and
proudly celebrate your union like by
calling yourself hard Carl's
you